welcome to this video I'll call Leah
corner one of the frequent guys right
seven games played against Somalia let's
see what we get here I really have no
memory those games okay let's do one of
the the same age games again why I'm
going a three and going on how the tech
b6 this move autumn okay i probably will
transpose if you go see five now no it
doesn't it's just playing without c5
interesting way to do it I don't really
know this line what is the dirt is
playing a very interesting III in the
specific in water no I don't know I
really don't know it interesting so
let's see he will probably win the c-4
pond anyway
I can I can play c5 yeah maybe it looks
kind of shaky though I should have taken
f5 first right this was this was a
stupid move order should have taken an
f5 first okay yeah this doesn't look too
bright from a strategic point of view
this was a stupid bishop on c1 Jack
Queen B 5 he plays c6 Quincy 593 not
good that it looks like that Gloria
looks bad yeah it's just totally totally
Datuk what I did there should have taken
on f5 which is much much better now I'm
just sitting here porn down and have a
rubbish position this is great my only
advice is whatever you do play better
than I am and I'm playing at the mode
this is not looking any good
I mean behind in development there on
top of it yeah maybe I can somehow get
in f5 and get there the night away i can
play Queen a four maybe ok I broke
before maybe has not replied to that
it's not really nice this position no
Queen a four week before
not so clear what you should do now if
I'm getting to take on c5 that's not a
little bad yeah f-for Quincy 59 f form I
can take a seven maybe rook takes rook
pietas rather embarrassing so he
probably has to take with the night if I
take a 790 was Queen to d5 what is my
move wow that's that's not so easy
25 is a big problem just threatening
made on them 22i 13 Queen d2 as well
well I wanted to take on a seven
originally but ok well maybe I have
queen bee son this is maybe a something
I can do Queen p7 it looks really really
problematic maybe it's ok c6 queen bee
tune Queen d5 queen b 76 queen bee two
should just about how old unless I'm
overlooking a tactic which is very much
possible ok Quincy five we can play now
very Quincy five check King edge 193 for
them for the night f to check can I have
g3 ok just to just grab the pawn to
makes quite some sense of course Quincy
too much so threatening much
and still 93 maybe 90 for one but still
this is maybe not that much more than a
check look everyone may be a tough tough
to play and I have to play with make it
still plain I have to actually and then
there were several stupid yahoo okay
when he can't still play night f2 and
then queen III or Queenie for and then
I'm sitting in this huge discovered
check which I probably cannot answer
adequately stupid I what what kind of
rubbish am I playing at the moment here
that's really embarrassing quindi 423
and very simple yeah this guy is going
to probably get in his first win against
me I have five wins two draws and after
Queen III or 24 I really don't see a
move there after that it's basically the
same thing he's threatening night age 34
the for the maid time morning I cannot
even like we be five
it's losing but I didn't see a move I
really didn't see a move can play
whatever 93 on whatever check
check Queen f2 probably enough not not
on air almost Queen 1803 into at least
not get checkmated
check check okay still it's too bad of
course but i'm not i'm not mated
immediately it's not really that i'm
hoping from much here but wait hip what
he lost you five where's the big trick
now check Wow check my king is safe now
black resigns ah what he came he
completely outplayed me and then then he
blundered 11 all the way in short order
yeah okay this was a really bad opening
result check let-let-let head let's have
a look probably I did something wrong
early maybe I should go a form
immediately trying to get this in and
maybe save save where this is probably
better right probably that's probably
that's better I have to do something
else here if I for I don't know the way
it went I mean what I definitely have to
do is see I have to take of course I
really can't sort of forgot to do that
and then this which is still not great
for me i am i'm sure it's clear on its
own it's a very positionally risky in
position well it just just better to do
that instead of what I played because
here I mean he's just in a fantasy
shame get all these good squares and
maybe i can get somewhere else with the
queer this is just bad it's a porn and
no no play no no nothing yeah Queen f4
he's just good but this is also ok I
mean I was really in a bad bad shape oh
yeah this was already winning yeah yeah
quite comparable to the game check ya
know if it is that I'm I'm sort of
hanging on they are not great but
somehow continues this game and here
yeah queen bee three seems to hold for
at least a little bit but Jesus is just
totally lost queeny's free was a bit
stronger even probably are preventing
this sir because he can just take and he
is winning but not shack like so quickly
Queen B 5 is a move check check Joe see
somehow completely ignored anything here
I mean you can just take it and here if
he just goes g5 it's over I really
didn't I mean he just didn't react to
the last idea that I had check my dear
white is definitely winning I mean also
on time but the position is also winning
now yeah there was a very lucky winner I
really playing badly at the moment need
to rely on luckier to have to win some
games okay I hope you were entertained
at least a little bit by the mistakes
thanks for watching